another thing that dr wright is not  allowed to do with the foundation dr  bright is not allowed to interact with  dr clef without the presence of a  responsible administrator after an  ordinary lunch meeting between the two  doctors resulted in a dozen casualties  several containment breaches and a glob  of mashed potatoes stuck to the ceiling  that won't budge no matter how hard the  cleaning staff scrubs it was decided  that the two should not be in the same  room without adequate supervision there  have been some follow-up questions  mainly from brighton clef about who  counts as adequate supervision so let's  clarify dr kondraki does not count agent  strzelenikov does not count dr mann does  not count so far no one counts as soon  as someone does count trust us you'll  know don't call us we'll call you